[Musique]
ça fait une semaine qu'on dort dans
cette banque est parce que parce que
dans notre chambre basse est plus
possible
on a fait une ouverture de fenêtres et
on n'aurait peut-être pas dû et ce qui
fait qu'en fait on a beaucoup on a des
odeurs de gaz falloir rebondir et du gaz
on pensait que c'était du gaz de ville
parce qu'après on sait pas on sait plus
on est perdu donc on est pris de
picotements dans la gorge donné qu'ils
qui comme si on respire est vraiment du
froid picotements dans les yeux et puis
constante fatigue des maux de tête à moi
c'est les bronches ça me prend les
bronches sommes fermes mené sa petite
très très mal aux bronches à la pression
du tout faits en fait tout doucement je
vois plus clair
mais voilà boire quand guillon qui sont
arrivés là récemment des problèmes de
ventre très mal l'estomac je pense
d'après moi c'est le stomacaux voilà
s'est garé bon ca de gars et ça fait
deux ans que j'ai à dire et quoi lâcher
ça fait deux ans que pour faire comme
normal bon voilà quoi
tout simplement puis après mon bac quand
on va voir votre médecin qui pratique en
gros c'est environnementale bon bah
voilà ça n'arrête à la ces
environnements talent un air
irrespirable des mots insoutenable des
douleurs de plus en plus fréquentes
c'est inné cyril ont repris la
briqueterie artisanale il y a neuf ans
ils travaillent tous les deux dans la
petite usine installée à côté de la
maison
au début tout allait bien mais leur rêve
d'une vie de famille à la campagne a peu
à peu tourné au cauchemar quand les
odeurs de gaz se sont infiltrés partout
notre cour être enfermé par
par des bâtiments voilà donc une fois
que ses rentrées lassansaa ne sortent
plus comme ça c'est compliqué à faire
sortir voilà donc ça rend dans le fond
de musique ces raisons font de lusine on
rentre ça va très bien dit mais après on
vomit ses curiosités quoi voilà fatigue
et résignés ils sont à bout de souffle
même s'ils sont inquiets pour leur santé
et celle de leurs enfants ils n'ont pas
les moyens d'engager une procédure
judiciaire
on a contacté un avocat enfin une
avocate et qui nous a dit clairement que
toute manière rien n'était plus viable
que que voilà c'était c'est très très
difficile c'est des analyses qui sont
déjà de très longues à faire nous
personnellement on aura ni la force
morale de la force physique de d'aller
plus loin en fin de de fer quelconque
procès qui pourrait durer jusqu'à cinq
ans pour prouver quoi est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose à prouver enfin on ne sait
plus on et voilà et en plus de ça on n'a
pas d'argent à pernes parce que ça fait
donc deux ans que l'usiné tourne au
ralenti est due à ses problèmes de santé
l'a donc au jour d'aujourd'hui nous on a
pris la décision de partir respire
ailleurs de trouver une habitation pour
aller respirer ailleurs aux heures de
fermeture de notre entreprise et revenir
travailler donc voilà bah comme tout le
monde pourrait faire quand il va au
travail quoi
est ce une coïncidence si lyn et cyril
vivre à trois kilomètres du centre
d'enfouissement de veolia à saint palais
chaque jour des centaines de camions
déversent des milliers de sacs poubelle
dans d'immenses alvéoles ces sacs
d'ordures ménagères seront ensuite
écrasé et enterré
laetitia vite elle aussi à côté du site
de veolia
elle a quitté la région parisienne pour
vivre à la campagne mais depuis un an
toutes les semaines
elle aussi subi des émanations de gaz de
plus en plus insupportable quand les
odeurs elles sont devenues encore de
plus en plus violente
parce qu'il ya des fois et surtout moi
dans ma salle à manger si vous voulez
j'ai pas chap
si vous avez vu c'est donc en fait s'il
pleut après quand l'on remonte
vous venez chez moi ça sent la mort
comme s'il y avait un cadavre sous ma
maison ça sent une odeur de putréfaction
ça me prend ici j'ai l'impression
franchement que alliés c'est la fin que
je vais y passer
j'ai mon corps qui tout le bras qui
s'engourdit j'arrive plus à des malaises
oui et surtout surtout moi ce qui
m'atteint vraiment c'est les yeux mes
yeux c'est quand ça se met vraiment les
odeurs elles sont vraiment là je peux
même pas les ouvrir des yeux parce que
d'églises ou ça me brûle mais c'est
horrible
jésus injectés de sang et c'est horrible
quand on peut parler d'eux
de ce qui se passe autour et tout ça les
médecins tout de suite ya un holà et et
en fait on passe plus pour des fous et
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'est pas pris
au sérieux jeu pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de lésion après enfin iliad il ya
des symptômes et qui ne reste pas un
gars qui quand on s'en va ailleurs passe
mais par contre aux firmes mesure du
temps et dans le temps on s'est passé
ces lésions là si on reste
continuellement ici à long terme si ça
va pas rester rester pour toujours quoi
non on va pas rester ne restera pas il
faut qu'on parte chose magali vite avec
sa fille dans l'ancienne maison de ses
parents
au début il n'a pas pensé à la proximité
de la décharge jusqu'à ce soir d'hiver
qui tourne mal pour lille où ma fille a
été quand même presse de migraine de
plus en plus régulièrement
juste un malaise un soir ont peut-être
lié ou pas effectivement un ça mais bon
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait vous
étiez la rue mais oui très mal de tête
et puis les ton album elle s'évanouit et
il y avait aussi ces odeurs là oui mais
oui oui c'était très fort à ces moments
là donc peut-être effectivement dû à
tout ça et elle a eu également des
ganglions nouveau des intestins
il n'y a pas si longtemps c'est la
première fois que je voyais ça les
médecins étaient un petit peu aussi une
capitale est un petit peu surpris dans
un premier temps l'explication
ils en ont pas eu des symptômes
inquiétants et le doute qui s'installe
je pense que et son courant s'il ya des
conséquences et des dangers
je pense qu'ils sont courants faut dire
la réalité est honnête il ya un problème
on my à un problème d'accord je pense
qu'il ya des moyens de le traiter faire
attention à l'eau comme je vous disais à
boire plus boire l'eau du robinet s'il
ya besoin de mettre des masques un petit
peu quand on sort suivant le temps si
c'est très fort et c'est pour protéger
je trouve qu'il ya pas de prévention il
pas de l'information particulière de
toute façon
ces émanations de gaz toxique à forte
dose incommode toujours les habitants
pourtant pour la rs l' agence régionale
de santé
les résultats des derniers relevés faits
par véolia sont rassurants les valeurs
de gaz détectée sont inférieurs aux
seuils toxiques
le risque d'exposition est donc
acceptable sur le court et le long terme
à saint palais on ne trie pas les
poubelles on enfouit les déchets ultimes
en les stockant sous terre pour bien
comprendre la méthode utilisée par
veolia il faut se représenter un
millefeuille de 18 mètres de haut
on creuse la terre en profondeur on pose
d'une membrane géotextile ensuite on
recouvre de cailloux et de déchets les
cailloux permettent de filtrer les
lixiviats ce sont les jus de poubelle on
ajoute une couche d'argile une deuxième
membranes et de la terre végétalisée
enfin réseau de tuyaux certains évacués
le biogaz dû à la fermentation des
déchets on est bien conscient qui a eu
des problèmes d'odeur c'est un gaz qui
est très odorant à des très faibles
doses par contre qu'on a pu démontrer
c'est qu'il n'y avait pas d'impact sur
la santé aussi bien sur des périodes
très courtes où les gens peuvent
ressentir des odeurs importante que sur
des périodes très longues d'exposition
de plusieurs mois plusieurs années
donc on a démontré qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'impact sur la santé par rapport aux
événements odorant que les riverains de
saint palais ont ressenti ces épisodes
odorant proviennent du gaz h2s du
sulfure d'hydrogène d odeur d'oeuf
pourri très toxique et même mortel à
forte dose pour réduire ces émanations
veolia cette équipe est de 7h cher
mobile
elle accélère la combustion des gaz dans
l'air des améliorations des travaux
contrôle et de très près par les
autorités
et on voit que même lorsqu'il ya eu des
pics on est très en deçà du seuil
donnant effet fixé par la préfecture
nous avons bien conscience de la
situation nous avaient mis en oeuvre des
moyens pour réduire et on est toujours
dans cet objectif là on continue à
surveiller réduire on sera là pour faire
les travaux nécessaires si ça devait se
reproduire je peux pas dire qu'il y en
aura plus jamais mais on est là pour
être vigilants pour veiller et on
travaille à réduire comme on l'a fait
depuis 2014
gisèle habite à 6 kilomètres du centre
d'enfouissement près d'achères
professeur de sport la retraite
amoureuse de la nature elle aime
cultiver ses 300 orchidées faire son
jardin potager et courir en forêt sauf
qu'elle a dû modifier son parcours et
changer de rythme
déconnez en forêt qu'on sent le gaz on
regrette d'habiter là
[Musique]
oui parce que vous sentez vous sentez
l'odeur donc forcément c'est pas normal
moi je suis là pour respirer le bon air
pur pour m'oxygéner mon mari habiter à
paris donc il a fui paris pour pouvoir
vivre à la campagne dans un autre
environnement et on s'aperçoit que ben
c'est pareil
presque d'habiter à côté de ceux du
centre c'est c'est aussi nocif que
d'habiter dans le centre de paris
gisèle souffre d'une sinusite chronique
depuis deux ans mais elle continue à
courir dans la forêt de saint palais
tous les jours le gaz suit les allées
c'est incroyable si les pouvoirs publics
s'ils font quelque chose c'est pas assez
s'est passé parce que la nature il faut
la préserver et on en a besoin les gens
veulent veulent
deux veulent se promener ils veulent
vivre correctement et ici on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas et je pense que c'est
pour nos enfants c'est pas bon
tout là à partir d'ici c'est tout veolia
et sur le côté gauche et à la ferme la
caroline le lieu-dit dakar où les
exportations et l'école alain et éleveur
depuis 20 ans ces chants se trouve à
quelques mètres du stockage de déchets
sa femme delphine est assistante
maternelle à domicile
tous deux ont assisté au début de
l'exploitation du site
très vite les odeurs de poubelles sont
devenues intolérables toute la famille a
souffert de migraines et d'insomnie le
couple est l'un des premiers à avoir
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
on a fini par
menacé d'aller porter plainte à la
gendarmerie de déposé des mains
courantes et là on a été un petit peu
plus pris au sérieux mais il a fallu
menacé et puis est encore pris au
sérieux
ça c'est vraiment et 20 à ranger entre
guillemets quand quand la population
beaucoup plus large a été a été
concernée je vous avais depuis quelques
années des quelques malformations sur
les veaux soit la naissance
des quelques mots aveugle et puis
beaucoup plus d'avortements
qu'auparavant il est vous les vaches qui
avortent auprès alors à l'automne et que
c'était pas prévu avant ça fait quatre
ans qu'on se bat quatre ans qu'on nous
mène en bateau quatre ans qu'on me dit
que ça va s'arranger et quatre ans qui
trouve toujours des petits soucis
derrière et que ça aggrave la situation
donc non on n'y croit plus il ya des
moments où on enfin on en a vraiment ras
le bol et nous on peut pas partir on ne
peut pas le mari travaille sur place
voilà on va pas quitter le travail de
monsieur parce que veolia nous pourrit
la vie entre guillemets donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya du vent c'est un ras-le-bol
c'est un ras-le-bol et on n'a plus envie
il existe 250 centres de stockage de ce
type en france ces leviers médecin
psychiatre à paris elle connaît bien ces
nuisances
elle possède une maison de famille en
haute-loire à côté de la décharge de
ville marché elle non plus n'a pas été
prise au sérieux
vous envie de vomir tout ça c'est dans
la tête sauf que je suis psychiatre je
peux dire que aussi dans la tête
le fait de vivre dans cette ambiance est
effectivement profondément anxiogène et
des princes aux jeunes parce que on a
honte
on sent la poubelle n'allait pas en soi
même on y vient un peu comme une
poubelle avec d'autres habitants ci lui
a créé une association droit à l'air pur
d'ap 43 après trois ans de combat
juridique la décharge a été
officiellement fermée le 31 décembre
2016 une victoire une revanche qui ne
résout pas tout selon elle je pense
qu'il ya un retard de prise en
considération du danger et de ce que
vivent les gens exposés à cette
proximité immédiate et contre quand même
les écouter leur ferme bassin bilan
médical et faire a minima une sorte
d'épidémiologie locale
le site d'enfouissement sera exploité
jusqu'en 2027 puis il restera sous la
surveillance de veolia pendant trente
ans après ce délai la terre restera en
friche
aucune construction ne sera possible une
terre condamné à côté de la forêt de
saint palais
[Musique]